i was going through postpartum anxiety i
had just come back from attorney leave
it was my second day back and joey told
me she didn't miss me she did miss me
zero you missed me so much you missed
fighting with me
i did not miss you
okay
i felt like i'd been slapped i started
crying and i had a panic attack in my
office downstairs afterward i threw up
it was a mess it was like a total mess
and
i just thought like i just don't think
this is wow women should be treated when
they come back from maternity leave
are you expecting an apology do you want
one i mean i'm telling you this audio
memoir is very eye-opening to say the
least i hope people like it it's not
meant to be like scorched earth maybe it
comes off that way
megan reveals she hasn't spoken to joy
since that final show there are other
uncensored stories in her almost six
hour audio memoir bad republican which
is out tomorrow on audible you say it
was never the host that were the issues
it was the backstage and the media
i could deal with host drama all day
long to me the thing that started having
a real impact on my mental and emotional
health was the the const and it became
constant like absolute constant
like leaking from the show the second
week i was there there was a bunch of
articles on gossip sites talking about
how nobody liked me on the show and i
was a disappointment and i was an ice
queen and you're a hated woman that
everybody thinks is a lunatic it would
take a toll on you i promise you without
a death i'm not gonna sit here and do
this hold on a second girl please stop
talking please stop talking right now i
won't talk the rest of the show no okay
your relationship with whoopi it
seemingly started so good she told your
dad that she was basically gonna have
your back
what was the catalyst that sparked this
negative dive in y'all's relationship i
think again it was covered and being via
satellite but we had a really beautiful
ending what did that ending look like we
just had a lovely conversation when i
left and she sent me some really lovely
text messages and i really wish would be
all the best i will always love her i
think she probably has still has love
for me someplace too i wish the show and
everyone truly all the best and
i hope they're not too mad but i don't
care if they are still good friends with
sunny and i would if i saw any of them i
would say hello and give them a hug joy
included and i wish them really
yeah i really am a forgiver hey you
never know you may be sitting back at
that table again would you ever no no
you don't know i actually am really
excited for other people to get to do it
too
it may come as a surprise but there's
only one chapter devoted to the view
megan also writes about her painful
miscarriage missing her father john
mccain and the one star who inspired her
to be raw and tell all i was actually
pretty inspired weirdly or not weirdly
by jessica simpson's memoir and i was
like oh my gosh she like goes with
everything and i i really responded to
it and i just felt like you know people
want to hear the truth
[Music]
you